hey youtubers its charlie happy DC week
everybody can stop freaking out the
flash is back it was actually a really
good episode featured zoom without
actually featuring zoom which was the
nice trick so just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet
there is a new round of the reverse
flash ring giveaway - all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video so here we
go the whole episode was really about
moving forward characters moving forward
like Caitlin wants to move forward patty
wants to move forward iris wants to move
forward but the people involved in all
those story arcs like Jay Garrick Barry
Wally
having trouble moving forward till they
slow down a little bit
segue to Ninja Turtle puns so let's do
top 5 WTF and then I'll do Easter eggs
they were there a couple of really good
ones in this episode starting with
number 5
Barry hallucinates zoom it has been
hallucinating zoom multiple times for
the last couple of weeks if you guys saw
that arrow video I posted earlier today
they had released an early clip of this
and it was it was like the first bit of
the episode the way that felt definitely
felt like it wasn't actually happening I
thought it might be a train turns out
that was the case regardless of what you
think of everyone's mental health on
Team flash they pretty much told him if
you want to move forward with patty you
have to tell her so he just he keeps
trying and things keep happening but
Wells is the one person who's like dude
don't tell her anybody that is precious
to you keep them as far away from this
as possible zoom will destroy them he
will take them from you obviously he's
talking about Jesse quick and he had
that really dark speech at the end of
the episode Tom Cavanagh was probably my
favorite thing about this episode but
basically Barry is committed to telling
patty the truth it is until number 4 WTF
the turtle comes in so there's actually
a funny backstory about this character
now obviously he's chief Terrell from
Battlestar everyone was like oh my god
it's the chief but the way the writers
were talking about it is they said they
wanted to have this funny side story
with Cisco like Cisco had been chasing
down this Moby Dick white whale
character all season long and just
hadn't told anyone about it when Joe
told Barry that he had a whole file of
unidentified metas those are people he
cataloged between season 1 & 2 if you'e
meant like he'd been working at the
police station with Joe Barry been off
doing his own thing so well the turtle
stuff began when team flash was on break
so there's probably a whole bunch of
people will hear about Cisco even quotes
Moby Dick from hell's heart I stab at
the
my one other memory of like a really
notable character saying that line was
mr. burns during a Simpsons episode now
the turtle character is actually someone
from the Jay Garrick comics from the
Golden Age comics he came back during
geoff johns run it was a slightly
different version of the character the
way he got his powers was a little bit
different the way he got his powers in
the geoff johns comics was he got in a
lab accident but it still amounted to
the same thing he's still leached speed
from people around him pretty much all
the versions were thieves of some sort
though but onto my number three WTF
capturing the turtle in black tie some
fun snow j-just a little bit of dancing
a little bit of fun till Barry has to
save patty
then gets drugged away I was convinced
that patty was gonna figure it out there
just seemed there were like a couple
moments in the episode progressively
where she started to get clues that the
turtle wanted to take her because he
takes things that are precious to other
people she is precious to the flash but
she just hasn't connected the dots but
on to my number two WTF joe and Wally's
start to reconcile after he catches him
drag racing nobody else in Keystone
would race me anymore I just love how
many flash references are working in
their total Kid Flash yeah it feels
really dark but I just I feel like this
is just good drama I don't think it's
going to a fairly dark place because of
the way they ended things with Chinese
food for the scene at the drag strip was
probably my favorite between the two of
them because you get all that Wally
backstory in that fight I'm the one that
takes care of my mother taking these
cards from other people is the only way
I can pay for her medical bills
Joe wants to be the dad I could break
into my pension I could figure something
out no I'll take care of this I'm the
man of the house all to be expected the
only Wally moment in the episode that
made me turn my head a little was when
he called Barry the white shadow and I
was like I don't I don't know what to do
but it definitely lets you know that
Wally has an edge to him and I think
that was the whole point finally though
on a my number one WTF moment the story
of zum-zum who gave him that silly name
let me tell you how you got that name
Cisco he lured a bunch of police
officers to their death and let one of
them survive so he could tell the story
when he was telling this story he said
that all he could see was blue lightning
zooming around as his comrades died and
that is how he got the name of zoom even
better the PostScript on that story is
that zoom went to that guy's house that
he
live after he had told his story and
spread the word about what zoom had done
and killed him too and yeah the speech
he had at the end was super dark about
how he would do anything to save his
daughter but I really think it's a
callback to the Farook episode remember
the reverse-flash was trying to use
Farooq's power to take speedforce from
the flash in season 1 this is almost the
exact same thing like he's abusing
metahumans to try and take down a flash
it's just not our flat she's trying to
use it to take down zoom we'll see how
it pays off but they they kind of threw
the turtle under the bus so to speak
cracked his shell just to show you how
far Harrison wells would go to save
Jesse quick so let me know in the
comments which our favorite moment from
the episode and I know a lot of you are
asking about the smoking speedforce gun
in the room what's the deal with Jay
Garrick being sick he said the only way
to fix it is to get his Speed Force back
so they have to defeat zoom so you can
see the look on his face he doesn't
think they're gonna be able to be in
soon so he just super depressed about it
all but my guess is without more
information that he needs the Speed
Force because he needs his enhanced
regeneration so he might have some form
of cancer it sounds like a normal
disease like a disease he might have had
before he became the flash but I was
actually really happy with the way
Caitlin responded to this like she's
like dude WTF don't you know what
happened to me last year my fiancee flew
into the eye of a wormhole of course I'm
gonna be pissed that you didn't tell me
you have a disease I don't want to have
another dude be reduced to atoms in
front of my face really awesome
character development for Caitlin's
character I don't think season 1 Caitlin
would have been quite so open with her
feelings with someone else like this
whole romance would probably never
happened with Jay Garrick cause she'd
have been so closed off nothing makes me
happier when a character is really open
about something that they want and they
just go for it they don't they don't sit
around waiting for some other character
to help them another good example is
what iris did with Wally West like she
tracked down Wally West and figured it
out and then that kind of set that
plotline off so that's kind of why I'm
hoping Patti does the same thing with
Barry and I know it seems like she's
going to Midway city
there have been scenes in previous
trailers that we haven't seen yet so
she's not gone from the show completely
she's just not gonna be around all the
time for the next couple of episodes the
next couple of episodes are gonna zero
in on some old classics though I know
the reverse-flash showed up at the end
but that's really kind of the tease for
the next episode
Gideon where the hell am i I love that
the T's are like the actual teaser for
the next episode where Harrison wells is
like
this is his story so think of episode 11
next week's episode as being a pure
reverse-flash explainer video like an
hour-long reverse-flash explainer cannot
wait it is gonna be so awesome
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from yesterday's videos Grand Admiral
Thrawn sorry you got thrown in the trash
can with the rest of the Star Wars EU
but you just want to reverse flash ring
so everything's okay so just be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel for contact details so a quick
reminder DC Week continues arrows gonna
post tomorrow then legends of tomorrow
is on Thursday whole bunch of stuff
happening with DC and Marvel this week
just in case you guys haven't seen it
you can click here for my Suicide Squad
trailer video and you can click here for
my Wonder Woman video thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow
you